a menos de un mes de las navidades
europa prepara su plan para las
festividades en alemania angela merkel
defendió este jueves el endurecimiento
de las restricciones hasta el 20 de
diciembre al no haber logrado el
descenso de los nuevos contagios la
canciller apeló a la responsabilidad de
la población durante el periodo navideño
de venta
este invierno será difícil pero
terminará especialmente ahora que
nuestros pensamientos están en la
navidad y nochevieja
deseo para todos nosotros que estemos
allí para el otro más que nunca si nos
tomamos esto en serio superaremos la
crisis
reino unido adelanto la introducción de
normas más duras que las anteriores al
confinamiento
debemos hacer los giros correctos
guiados por la ciencia la mayoría de
inglaterra estará en el nivel 2 pero en
un número significativo de áreas temo
que se necesitarán nivel 3 para reducir
el número de casos
en los últimos días la media de casos
diarios en francia es de 15.000 por lo
que el gobierno calcula que en la
segunda semana de diciembre podría estar
por debajo de 5000 este jueves el primer
ministro anunció un fin progresivo de
las restricciones para salir del
confinamiento pero sin bajar la
vigilancia
la literatura y la literatura científica
y nuestra propia experiencia
especialmente durante las vacaciones de
verano han demostrado que estos momentos
de reuniones festivas y amistosas cuando
uno baja la guardia o usa menos de una
máscara son particularmente riesgosos
por lo tanto es imperativo que limite el
número de personas en la mesa y evite
las grandes reuniones
con más de 12 millones de casos europa
representa el 20 por ciento de los
contagios del mundo